okay so if you watch or listen to our
show you probably already know that when
I open a story by saying hey there was a
rare moment of sanity on Fox News it's
almost always shepard smith and
sometimes like every once in a while it
will be chris wallace today's the
exception to that trend yes
Trump was called out for his lies yes it
was on Fox News yes it was a male anchor
but it was not Shep Smith and it was not
Chris Wallace it was actually Neil
Cavuto
and the topic was the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in hush money that
repayment admission from Rudy Giuliani
that we've talked about relating to
Trump's repayment of that hush money
Neil Cavuto did a monologue and called
what's going on out as lies but he
didn't actually use that word right but
we could all sort of understand what he
was saying Cavuto made it very clear
that the story is not making any sense
Trump denied any knowledge of it Rudy
Giuliani says Trump did pay back but
then sort of walks it back which we'll
talk about later it's just not making
any sense here is Neil Cavuto on Fox
News pointing this out president Trump
is fond of calling out the media on fake
news but is he the one giving them very
real ammunition maybe not intentionally
I'll even give you the benefit of doubt
mr. president say maybe not deliberately
but consistently Wade you consistently
so let me be clear mr. president how can
you drain the swamp if you're the one
who keeps muddying the waters you didn't
know about that $130,000 payment to a
porn star I think it did said you knew
nothing about how your former lawyer
Michael Cohen handle this until
acknowledging today you were the guy
behind the retainer payment that took
care of this you insist that money from
the campaign or campaign contributions
played no role in this transaction of
that you're short thing is not even 24
hours ago sir you couldn't recall any of
this and you seem very sure now I'm not
saying you're a liar you're president
you're busy I'm just having a devil of a
time figuring out which news this thing
let's just say your own words on lots of
stuff give me shall I say lots of pause
like the time you said the Russians
didn't interfere in the 20
sixteen election until a lot of
Republicans had to remind you they did
came back months later and you said well
I never said that Russia didn't meddle
in the election when in fact you had a
lot now none of this makes me a never
Trump er just always confused like when
you claim your tax plan was the biggest
in US history when it wasn't or that the
bill you signed to make it all happen
would cost you a fortune when it turns
out it is going to help make you a
bigger fortune or that your job approval
numbers really aren't that bad relative
to other presidents at this stage when
they're actually worse than most
presidents at this stage that can change
but what's weird is this pattern does
not so you get the idea this is probably
the best we can hope for on fox news
other than Shepard Smith and certainly
you know Neil Cavuto doesn't go far
enough here he's still using careful
language it's Fox News after all he's
not going to just say straight up this
guy's been lying to us and clearly
deliberately for a very long time but it
still is a move in the direction of even
Fox News getting to the end of what
they're willing to tolerate from Trump
and then of course predictable the Fox
News audience crushing Cavuto for even
meekly suggesting that maybe some of the
things are revered mr. president has
said might not have been accurate Fox
News viewers have been tweeting just
horrible things to Neil Cavuto calling
him a leftist liberal and a [ __ ] saying
they won't be watching his show anymore
enjoy your low ratings he needs to be
shipped out and the next day Kabuto had
to do sort of a clarification he spent 7
and a half minutes reading angry tweets
and responding to lots of them
individually and sort of saying hey
listen I'm not a never Trump or take a
look anyway fake news works both ways
Kenny so does consistency every fact I
presented last night was real every
comment I use from the president was his
not my words his words word for word not
my tweets his tweet nothing was faked
everything I shared was real no matter
the Bob emails you're a smug pompous
windbag I hope that you croak on that
pork chop tonight wait a minute yeah the
other thing to bear in mind here is that
just because Neil Cavuto said some of
the things our president has been saying
seem to be inaccurate or inconsistent he
and Fox News don't deserve
journalism awards right for timidly
acquiescing to the completely undeniable
reality that trumps not being honest
this is one of the most dishonest
presidents in history the only reason
it's notable is that Fox News has been
the propaganda machine for Trump and if
you're white waiting around for Fox News
to take this trend or take this approach
on all of its shows like Fox and Friends
I would not hold my breath
the problem with Fox News being almost a
100% uninterrupted stream of total
propaganda
is that you tell the truth once here
just basically saying sometimes Trump's
not 100% honest and you get crushed and
people get really really mad so the best
possible scenario here is that maybe Fox
is starting to tear itself apart or eat
itself whatever analogy you want to use
the other is this might lead to a total
housecleaning at Fox News to get
everybody 100% on message either away
I'm super interested in watching what
happens on Fox News and you know I don't
watch a lot of MSNBC but a lot of people
think of MSNBC as the left-wing
equivalent of Fox News yeah if an MSNBC
host was critical of Barack Obama or
Hillary Clinton I would actually kind of
like it especially coming from them yeah
if they were being critical on the right
things but you never see that on Fox
News or at least not as much because the
committee Trump is just won't have it
not in the same way yeah and of course
Jang Kyogre from The Young Turks has the
story about how he when he was hosting
on MSNBC and there was a discussion or a
possible longer term job forum how one
of the things he was told was you got to
sort of step away a little bit from the
criticism of President Obama but towards
the end of Obama's presidency you
arguably saw more dissenting voices from
the left on MSNBC in a lot of ways we
are talking about two profit-driven
corporate news outlets whose editorial
positions are different but that dynamic
is one that is going to be very very
hard to break at Fox News especially if
their core profitable audience starts to
turn away because they start to say wait
a second we're not getting the message
that we were expecting and hoping to get
from Fox News send me your thoughts
what's going on with Cavuto what do you
think is driving him to do this because
he could also just do another segment
right he didn't didn't have to do this
story I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David
show today's episode of the program is
made possible in part by Cody which is
an innovative new cryptocurrency and
online payment platform that wants to
revolutionize how we send and receive
online payments cody stands for currency
of the internet and the goal is to build
an infrastructure for online payments
that simple transparent trustworthy
instantaneous as well as scalable and
today's payment solutions have a number
of different trust and usability
problems whether it's between consumers
or between businesses or between
consumers and businesses and Cody wants
to solve a lot of those problems through
their currency and platform which unlike
a lot of the Kryptos and block chains
that are out there have actually been
created specifically and solely to be
used for payments cody has set out to do
this by using innovative base layer
protocol in the form of a directed
acyclic graph based ledger built from
transactions connected through time by
harnessing trust based algorithms if
you're watching this on youtube you can
find out more about cody and their
initial coin offering in the links below
this video this is not financial advice
and everybody should do their own
research